une messe sur une piste utilisée
d'habitude par des autos tamponneuses
une image insolite que l'on voit tous
les ans à la Fête des Loges dans la
forêt de Saint-Germain-en-Laye pendant
une heure tous les forains et invités se
réunissent devant cet hôtel improvisée
ici on célèbre la saint FIAC le saint
patron des jardiniers et des maraîchers
c'est très original et en même temps
c'est très traditionnel dans toutes les
grandes fêtes foraines il y a toujours
au milieu de la fête à un moment la
célébration de la Messe parce que le
monde forain est un monde de chrétiens
le Seigneur Jésus est présent dans dans
toute situation de vie il est présent là
aussi où les hommes et les femmes se
réjouissent et viennent passer du bon
temps c'est vraiment une fête qui est
importante pour nous et qui nous tient
vraiment à cœur c'est un moment où on
peut justement communier tous tous
ensemble et se rassembler un peu tous en
famille cet événement est l'une des
traditions les plus anciennes du diocèse
de Versailles elle prend son origine
avec une confrérie installée sur le site
d'éloge en 1652 une procession s'y
rendait chaque été pour célébrer une
messe et attirer des forains aujourd'hui
cette fête fait partie de l'histoire de
la ville de Saint-
ça a toujours été comme ça là toujours
connu comme ça on est dans une
célébration chrétienne un peu
particulière en y associant les
paroisses de Saint-Germain le curé
Étienne Guillet de Trappes un groupe de
Trappes ça fait partie des cultures et
des traditions Saint-Germain c'est une
ville de culture et tradition on y est
très attaché comme on est très attaché
au monde forain ça fait partie de notre
ADN la messe est ensuite prolongée dans
l'allée des cuisines autour d'un bon
repas entre tous les participants la
370e édition de cette Fête des Loges se
poursuivent jusqu'au 20 août dans la
forêt de Saint-Germain-en-Laye
[Musique]